one of South Africa's opposition parties
the economic freedom fighters is calling
for a national shutdown and mass
protests it says it wants the president
to be removed and rolling power outages
to end the party's warning businesses to
close or risk being looted security has
been tightened at government buildings
and the Army has been deployed well for
moreness we're going to bring in
haramatasa from Pretoria what are the
organizers of the March hoping to
achieve home
[Music]
we cannot just sit for the arms while
the country collapses that is what
Julius malema has said he is the leader
of the opposition EFA party he wants his
supporters and ordinary South Africans
to come and protest with him calling for
President surabha to resign he wants
also to protest about the economy the
high cost of living in South Africa and
the electricity crisis some areas in
this country can go for more than 10
hours without power the police and army
have been deployed throughout the
country with looting and damage to
property as Africans are watching these
events very very closely they don't want
to repeat what many of them don't want
to repeat or what happened back in 2021
when rights broke out over the economy
hundreds of people were killed and a lot
of property was damaged but one thing to
bear in mind is that it's a long weekend
here in South Africa Tuesday is a public
holiday so may many people have taken
Monday off on vacation visiting family
and friends so that that could affect
the numbers at the protest today Ohio
obviously as we mentioned rolling power
outage is just one of the the concerns
that the people have there has the
government been responding to these
issues
[Music]
I'm not frustrated and this government
is trying to do all they can to resolve
all these issues he appointed the
country's first electricity Minister but
critics are saying it's yet another
Ministry using public funds to do the
job of what other Ministries should have
been doing in the first place remember
Paulson says he feels that these
protests are suspicious in terms of
their timing he says that he feels its
opposition parties who are trying to
position themselves ahead of Elections
next year trying to weaken the ruling a
and see savannahs are saying it's more
complicated than that they're saying
these protests highlights the huge used
divisions in South Africa between the
people themselves between different
political parties and as well as
divisions within the ruling A and C
party there are people who feel that
since the AMC took over power in 1994
they feel some of those politicians in
that party are no longer working for the
best interests of the country it's about
their own interests that's why some
opposition supporters and some old East
Africans art Mysteries today saying
they're going to march in protest
from Pretoria that's how to thank you
very much indeed